the cdc's updated guidelines dominating
the news cycle at a time when the
president is facing criticism
on multiple fronts from his response to
rising violence in the middle east
to his handling of our southern border
the former assistant health secretary
under president trump
admiral brett joy says this about the
questionable timing
look at the whirlwind that happened on
wednesday night dr wolinski was
absolutely in transient in her position
yesterday morning dr fauci said yeah you
still need to wear a mask
indoors and even outdoors if you're in a
crowd and by the afternoon it was all
over
these decisions are not pure science and
we shouldn't look at that way
um it's not just about infection control
it's about opening up america it's about
liberties it's about how we run our
country
and there was no scientific knowledge
manifestation that happened yesterday
in fact when you look at the cdc website
and they say what's the science behind
it it goes back to an april 2nd website
he's exactly right dr nicole sapphire i
know admiral zhua personally i worked
with him during my time in the trump
administration he is someone who has
been
totally grounded in the science as have
you so what do you make of the timing
uh was this too little too late
well you know it's interesting because i
was actually covering it live yesterday
when those announcements were made
and when they were asked the question
you know it was there new science that
came out or is this just because of
political pressure and then the answer
was no no new data came out and then
she's quoted a couple of studies in my
head i'm like
i remember reading that like the first
couple of days of april and um you know
admiral draw is completely correct
a lot of the data that they have been
referring to has been out for a couple
months but that's been pretty consistent
the cdc
has been about two to three months
behind the data when it comes to
updating their regulation their
recommendations and
you know i can tell you it's a great
foot forward but you know i
actually don't think they went even far
enough because they're continuing to
ignore the science when it comes to this
they've had tunnel vision about getting
to zero cases
at the detriment of our children of our
businesses our economy and mental health
what they have to do at this point is is
get us open and they are only addressing
those who are vaccinated
president biden in my opinion put out a
dangerous tweet yesterday
he said if you get vaccinated take off
your mask if you don't get vaccinated
essentially
you have to keep wearing a mask until
you do that is just not
true he completely ignored those
unvaccinated the children
those who have contraindications to
vaccination and what about the millions
who have recovered with natural immunity
what about the reliable data that shows
natural immunity from infection
is provides just as much protection as
the vaccine
they continue to ignore that and that is
ex that is extremely irresponsible
that's exactly right and dr scott atlas
has been talking about natural immunity
for some time
and they tried to run him out of
washington dc looks like he was exactly
right
raymond coming to you i found this
sought to be so interesting the sound
bite defending president biden's wearing
of a mask it's from white house senior
advisor for covid response andy slavitt
here's what he said about why biden was
wearing a mask as recently
as wednesday i'm not sure that the
president is the average
person i i personally think there's a
lot of protections around the president
why does he need lots of secret service
agents why does he
why do they you know belt and suspender
everything with the president because
he's a very important person
and i think you shouldn't take your your
mark just by what you see in the oval
office i think most people
if you're indoors around other people
that are vaccinated
cd says it's okay um and i think you
should listen to the cdc on that
so the lead coveted advisor says to us
biden is so important that he needs to
wear a mask wednesday
thursday's cdc guidelines are rescinded
because none of us are important and
apparently
now the science is on the side of not
wearing the mask okay
you know this is this is like when biden
came in
we were told science is back but after
watching this play out
i'm thinking of whitney houston i'll
steal the line
this science is whack okay none of this
adds up
um the their prognostications on the
spread were wrong
at christmas time they said schools and
restaurants and gyms were going to be
super spreaders
none of that happened and as dr sapphire
said a moment ago
what about the natural immunity of our
children yet today
you have the cdc uh leader
dr welinski on the today show and she
said this
it will be hard to let go of masks
people
may want to continue wearing them we
should be able to do that
in their own time they'll let go of it
when did masks
become pets that that's my problem in
all of this
uh immunity as dr sapphire was saying we
don't hear anything about t
cell immunity from the cdc or the innate
immunity of these children
the very idea that you say vaccinated
people can go about their business and
take masks off
but children in a playground outside
have to be masked that's what dr fauci
said yesterday
none of this adds up it makes you feel
that this information is being
hoarded from us and only leaked out with
political intent and with a political
edge basically to blunt these other
horrific stories that are swamping this
white house
and i hate to tell the cdc director it
will not be hard for me to let go of my
mask i may
have a bonfire down here in florida
you're all welcome me neither
my mine was already gone so it was easy
it was an easy party
decoupling julian coming to you look
i worked in the trump administration on
operation warp speed and i remember
being in the oval office with the
president and watching him put
immense pressure on the officials around
him the science officials saying look
we've got to get this vaccine out
bust through whatever you have to bust
through do it safely but we've got to
not let regulation stand in our way not
only that but he planned for
producing this vaccine in advance it was
remarkable but
yet the biden administration gives very
little credit to the fact that we're at
this point
without mass vaccinated country uh we
don't often see them give credit to the
prior administration
we don't and you know in large part i
think it's be part of the natural
transition
from you know a republican to a
democratic administration but we have
also seen the white house
kind of go out of their way sometimes
including what the vice president
said during the first week of the
administration which was that
we had essentially no vaccine rollout
plan when we came to office which the
entire nation knows was
you know not exactly the truth i if you
guys will just bear with me for a second
i want to ask
um dr sapphire a question i don't know
if this is like a clear-cut
answer dr sapphire but i'm bringing it
up because it seems like nobody's
talking about it but a lot of people
have been tweeting me about it later
lately they're saying there are a whole
lot of americans
who for them for medical pre-existing
medical reasons
a vaccine is not an option at all
or it's not an optimal option can you
talk to us about
before we start shaming everybody now
who doesn't have a vaccine
talk to us about some of the medical
conditions
out there that will prevent reasonable
minded americans not just because
they're being anti-vaxxers but because
their
doctors and physicians are recommending
they don't get the vaccine talk to us
about some of those
conditions i don't really know anything
about it
well so it's very important to
differentiate between
you know the traditional anti-vaxxers
who find skepticism with anything that's
related to vaccines
and the vaccine hesitant and the vaccine
hesitant
i understand why they hesitate and there
are some medical conditions where
it's not necessarily contraindicated to
get the vaccine but the truth is
we don't have a lot of data on it
specifically those who have
immunocompromised
systems as well as some autoimmune
diseases of course those who have severe
allergies there can be a
contraindication there
in the very beginning um the american
college of rheumatology
came out saying you know they did
recommend people with autoimmune disease
get the vaccine
they were starting to see some upticks
in some of the flares
after those with autoimmune disease
getting the vaccine but here's the thing
and here's the conversation that people
need to have with their doctors
you know we have treatments for
autoimmune flares we have treatments for
a lot of things
we still don't actually have a silver
bullet in terms of treating severe covet
19.
so this is a big conversation risk and
benefit with your physician
i do not think that the president should
be going out there and saying you will
have to wear a mask until you get a
vaccine i think that is dangerous and i
think that is irresponsible
and i think this is a choice that needs
to come between the patient
and their physician and i think the
president and the cdc need to stay out
of it
so it's almost like the president is
saying you know
those who with pre-existing medical
conditions who might not want to get the
vaccine are going to have to bear the
special burden
that healthy people uh won't have to is
that right
it what's a well it's a double-edged
sword because those with chronic medical
conditions are at a higher risk for
covid19 those are the ones that we are
seeing hospitalized
but again there have been some concerns
with the vaccines with people with
certain conditions
i will say the data to date does not
show exacerbation of these conditions
and they really are proving to be safe
in just about everyone but again it's
okay to be hesitant as long as you have
a conversation and educate yourself
and if your physician recommends against
it i don't think it is fair for the
president or the cdc to say you have to
continue wearing a mask
it is their choice if they want to wear
a mask they know that they are at an
increased risk
yeah so it's a really important point
thank you for for bringing that up
julian emily um to you i want to
have you button up this segment for us
because you and i were talking this
morning about kind of the legal morass
that some of these
guidelines create and how one governor
in particular
a very good one has a solution to that
that's exactly right governor desantis
in florida has now come out and said
that he's going
to grant clemency essentially and
evaluate any
pending criminal charges against any uh
business owner and operator that is
facing charges
for remaining opening during the
lockdown that's fantastic that's
something i've been advocating for this
whole time
but i want to point out as well the
deeper under layer and that's of the
regulation and the licensure
and that's been yielded as a weapon this
entire time throughout
all states there's so many cases that
are still simmering
let's take sunday river brewing co up in
maine
they were the most inspected restaurant
in all of maine they had their liquor
license taken away multiple times
their operating and health licenses
taken away an administrative hearing
officer said they were quote an
imminent threat to public health and
safety
their doors remain closed and this is
against the backdrop
of in maine 55 covid deaths
you know how many families depend on the
brewery for their livelihoods
58. now let's take as well max public
house in staten island designated an
orange zone
just a block away from a less
restrictive zone there in new york state
that owner was arrested their licenses
taken away as well
in december alone he faced 25 criminal
summonses by the state of new york
this as the homicide rate and shootings
alone are up 97 percent
doesn't the state have better things to
do than prosecute and persecute
business owners just trying to maintain
their livelihood and even in the state
where i'm sitting in washington state
the owner of farm boy restaurant
faced fines of up to two thousand
dollars a day
when the reason they were staying open
is because they couldn't afford to close
so it's all of these all of these
licensure restrictions
these heavy fines and again the yielding
of a weapon
by the health departments that i hope
all of our elected
official elected officials will expunge
moving forward because there's a lot
more people suffering than just the good
people under good governor desantis's
watch there in florida
well said liberty matters that's
incredible emily thanks for bringing
that to light